mes chers compatriotes les 11 et 18 juin
prochain vous allez choisir vos députés
ce sont eux qui au parlement vont fixer
le cadre général des grandes
orientations à venir pour notre pays
je suis fier régions je suis candidat
dans la meuse je vote majorité pour la
france pour que la france rurale ne soit
plus la grande oubliée je suis le dit
léger je suis candidat sur la troisième
circonscription de l'isère
aujourd'hui je m'engage pour la majorité
pour la france parce que je crois en
cette droite qui a du coeur la droite
qui a des élus de proximité qui
s'engagent pour vous je suis guillaume
ii car candidat dans le bas je vote la
majorité pour la france parce que les
français attendent une majorité claire
et cohérente
je suis valérie bros candidate les
républicains dans la 4e circonscription
des français établis hors de france qui
recouvre les pays du benelux je me
présente pour défendre les valeurs
européennes qui sont aussi celles de
notre mouvement
le moins projet nous sommes prêts à le
mettre en oeuvre un projet
d'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat avec
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires nous baisserons l'impôt
sur le revenu de 10 % un projet de refus
de l'augmentation spectaculaire de la
csg qui va impacter les retraités les
fonctionnaires les professionnels
libéraux et qui va en réalité un pacte
et toute la société française
nous sommes prêts également parce que
notre projet veut réarmer l'état
restaurer son autorité
nous sommes favorables au rétablissement
des peines planchers nous sommes
favorables
une négociation de schengen pour
protéger nos frontières et éviter un
chaos migratoires que nous ne pouvons
pas accueillir
nous avons une équipe rassemblée soudée
nous avons un renouvellement forts de
nos candidats deux jeunes hommes et
femmes qui incarnent une génération qui
se lève qui demande un espoir
ils sont là au rendez vous ils sont à
vos côtés les 11 et 18 juin prochains
donnant une majorité pour la france pour
que vive la république
et pour que vive la france
[Musique]